un talent de coloriste et une
sensibilité caractéristique durant toute
sa carrière le photographe Bruno Barbet
s'est distingué par sa singularité une
marque de fabrique tout droit inspirée
de son pays d'origine le
Maroc parmi tous ces clichés ce sont
ceux du monde méditerranéen qui ont été
choisis par la chapelle de Claire
Fontaine pour lui rendre hommage je
trouve qu'il a une manière d'approcher
les sites et les gens
et c'est vrai qu'en plus bah le Maroc
pour lui c'est se faisait un donc ça
c'était la première chose et la deuxième
on a voulu montrer le Portugal et
l'Espagne qui sont des pays qui n'ont à
ma connaissance jamais été montrés en
[Musique]
France il était d'abord un pour moi un
coloriste et l'émission qui lui était
demandé que ce soit en tant que
journaliste liste de guerre ou
géographique était plus une excuse pour
moi enfin je l'analyse comme ça pour
pour faire d'abord son travail de
créateur coloriste grâce à son talent
dans les années 60 Bruno Barbet intègre
l'agence de presse Magnum il va alors
parcourir le monde pour réaliser ses
clichés donnant parfois lieu à des
scènes surprenantes comme cette photo
prise à faise elle était prise du haut
d'un minaret et pour arriver à l'prendre
de de cette façon euh qu'elle qu'elle
soit comme si elle était prise du ciel
il s'est fait tenir par un un ami
marocain qui le qui il avait accroché
des ficelles de façon à ce que il puisse
se pencher en avant et arriver à ce que
la photo soit euh comme vue du ciel
héritage d'un photographe discret et
engagé témoin des bouleversements de nos
sociétés depuis plus de 50 ans les
clichés de Bruno sont exposé à travers
le monde 3 ans après son décès ses
œuvres continuent de
fasciner